alright let's get started
today with our lecture on factor markets
so when we talked about producer theory
we talked about input prices that firms
had prices for their wages in their
capital and we just sort of posed those
as given I just sort of gave you values
for the wage and the rental rate of
capital but we never really talked about
where those prices come from given that
they may be the most important prices on
our whole economy it's probably worth
spending a little time on talking about
where do W and are actually come from
and that's will do for the next three
lectures is talk about factor markets
talk about the markets that give us the
price of labor and capital
we're gonna start by talking about
factor demand the general demand for
labor and capital and then we'll move on
to talk about factors supply where does
supply come from will then develop the
equilibrium and that will tell us where
wages and the interest rate come from so
that's sort of the map of where we're
going is we're basically to develop the
markets that give us the wage rate and
the interest rate so let's start with
factor demand factor demand and let's
start and we're going to start with the
cleanest case we're gonna assume that
factor markets are perfectly competitive
so unless I say otherwise we're assuming
the market for workers or the market for
machines or capital it's perfectly
competitive ok we'll come back and bend
that a little bit later so what that
means is that there's basically many
sellers and buyers ok so any worker ok
is basically competing with lots of
workers for jobs any firm has commuted
lots of firms to hire the workers ok and
we're also gonna so we're going to
assume a perfectly competitive input
market that is lots of firms and workers
competing to match with each other we're
also going to assume a perfectly
competitive output market that is we're
gonna examine this for the case not of a
monopoly firm but of a totally
competitive firm so just as you're
perfectly competitive firm
competing with lots of other firms too
workers ok so let's start by talking
about short-run labor demand in this
context let's talk about short-run labor
demand now in the short-run capital is
fixed so our decision is just do we add
another worker or not or another hour of
labor not like I said - so the unit's
don't really matter here but let's think
in terms of workers do we add another
worker or not okay well as with
everything else in this course who want
to consider the marginal benefits of the
marginal cost of that decision the
marginal benefit of of an extra worker
is that one extra unit of labour raises
productivity by the marginal product of
labor ok one more unit of labour raises
our output by the marginal product of
labor ok but that's not the only part of
the benefit because we don't actually
care as a firm about units of output we
care about revenues so the benefit of a
worker is not just the how many units it
produces but the value of those units ok
and what is the value of the next unit
produced it's the marginal revenue so
the value of the next unit of labour is
what we call the marginal revenue
product M are P sub L the marginal
revenue product is the Martyr product of
labour times marginal revenue that's the
benefit of another unit of labour it's
not just what they make but what it's
worth ok it's not just what they make
but what it's worth okay so that's the
marginal benefit the value of another
unit of labour is he makes a marginal
revenue product amount more stuff and
you sell that at the marginal revenue
that's the marginal benefit what's the
marginal cost of another unit of labour
this is the marginal benefit of another
unit of labour what's the marginal cost
well the marginal cost of the labor is
just the wage so we simply set this
equal to the wage we set the marginal
product of labor
equal to the wage and that gives us our
optimization condition for the out full
amount of labor the firms want to demand
is to set the marginal revenue product
of labor equal to the wage marginal
benefits of hiring another unit of labor
equals the marginal cost of hiring
another unit of labor now to go further
remember I said this is a perfectly
competitive output market so what is the
marginal revenue and a perfectly
competitive output market what's the
marginal revenue of a firm producing
yeah price so you can write this more to
say that once that the marginal product
of labor times the price equal to the
wage okay so basically what we're saying
here think about it is hire workers
until the cost of the next unit of labor
is the same as what that unit will
actually produce for you
okay the next year's labor cost eww it
produces for you MPL times P so you want
to hire workers until that condition is
met okay so think about that figure
fifteen one sort of shows this okay we
have I we have a supply of Labor in 51
that's horizontal because we're assuming
a competitive market for workers okay
we're sooo competitive market for
workers that is if a perfectly
competitive market so if I try to pay
workers one penny more than other firms
every worker in the world will want to
work for me if I pay workers one penny
less than other firms no workers will
want to work for me that's what a
perfectly competitive labor market means
that literally I am a price taker in the
input market I don't get to set the wage
okay III don't get to set the wage the
wage is given to me by the labor by the
labor market so just like a perfectly
competitive firm doesn't get to set the
price their product it's given to them
by the competitive market a perfectly
competitive firm in the input market
doesn't get to set the wage they pay its
given to them through the kind of
process that delivered us our prices on
the output side okay so we get a
horizontal labor supply curve and then
we have this downward sloping labor
demand curve why is it downward sloping
someone raise their hand and tell me why
is the labor demand curve downwards
downward sloping yeah exactly
the diminishing marginal product of
labor means you have a downward sloping
marginal benefit of Labor
each additionally remember holding
capital fix is only one shovel so each
additional worker adds less and less to
digging that hole okay
so Marge products diminishing since P is
a constant that doesn't really affect
the slope I mean it affects the slope it
doesn't really affect this is a sign it
doesn't affect the sign its diminishing
because the marginal product of labor is
diminishing so the equilibrium is where
they intersect so the bottom line this
is complicated and new the bottom line
intuition is to think about as I decide
whether to hire one more one more hour
of work you've got a firm you've got a
side do I want worker to work one more
hour you do the trade-off of what am I
going to pay them for an hour versus
what are they gonna get me for an hour
what they're gonna get me is their
marginal product times the price okay
now a that um so in other words the
reasons not just a marginal product is
the managing of two workers or equally
productive with one more out work they
each make three more units well let's
say in one case a unit is a computer
chip okay in another case a unit is a
potato chip okay we clearly would not
want to pay the same wage to someone who
bruises three more computer chips is
owned ruses three more potato chips okay
we'd want to pay a lot more the person
three more computer chips why oxen
computers aren't currently valuable in
fact the ten chips are much more
delicious than computer chips because
they sell they sell for a higher price
so therefore you'd want to pay more to
the worker peruses more unit so more
valuable good so let's uh let's think
about a Sports example okay and I
realize we're all about baseball today
is we should be Go Red Sox but let's
focus on basketball for a minute
okay now imagine your owner of a team in
the NBA the National Basketball
Association and you're trying to decide
how much to pay one of your players so
basically in that case your goal is to
your what your goal is wins that's the
goal that's the profit trying to
maximize your wins let's say you
probably trying to maximize your your
revenues from ads and stuff but assume
that's proportional to wins okay it's in
the face of the more you win the more
money you make so let's say the thing
you're trying to maximize his wins okay
so your labor demand the marginal
product you care about is the
contribution of the next player to your
wind total that's we care about the
marginal product of labor is how much
does that next player add to my wind
total okay so for example LeBron James
the best player in basketball arguably
that's play in history we could have
that we have the LeBron versus Michael
debate some other time okay LeBron James
makes 31 million dollars and that's
because his marginal product is enormous
he adds a huge amount of wins to any
team okay will excuse with it
we'll run the experiment to watch how
the Cleveland Cavaliers tanked this year
once the Bron is left okay now other
players don't make as much let's compare
LeBron James to Nate Robinson
you guys might not know Nate Robinson is
he's one of the shortest players in
history of the NBA at a paltry five nine
which sounds pretty tall to you and I
but his tiny for the NBA okay he was a
very exciting player it's kind of fun
watch this little guy run among these
giants okay um but uh but he was just
okay he wasn't a great player as a fine
player he made about two million dollars
a year by the end of his career okay so
basically you're LeBron maked 31 million
and Nate Robinson make it 2 million and
that's sort of related to their marginal
products abroad adds a lot more to your
wits now what happened is Nate Nate
Robinson quit basketball in the US and
would play basketball in Israel in
Israel they love basketball they have a
league and he went to Israel and he was
dominant he was the best player in
Israel because they don't they're not as
good as the US okay so his marginal
product went way up Nate Robinson went
from being so on a small margin Proctor
may be the highest marginal product in
the league and it's wage went down
from 2 million to 500,000 see the
situation where someone's marginal
product went way up and their wage went
down why yeah right cuz the margin
product went up but the price went way
down okay and what we care about is the
wage is equal the market product times
the price see a situation where a player
got better but got paid less because
they got better he moved from make
computer chips to making potato chips
okay he moved from a market where he was
earning a valuable commodity to one
rezoning one that was much less so so
basically it's a situation that example
shows why she care about both the
quantity of the additional worker and
the value of what they're producing okay
any questions about that yeah no single
hour of work is paid equally it's not
equal march progress we're talking about
is a market let's think about a
perfectly competitive
I probably two fastest let's say a
perfectly competitive output market is
where the firm's sell the goods into a
market where people have perfect
information it can shop across all firms
easily a perfectly competitive input
market it's where firms hire workers in
a situation workers have perfect
information and compare across law firms
equally so basically the point is think
about it perfectly clear about a
perfectly competitive output market
think about a market where lots of
people are shopping and all the options
are in front of them I've heard early
competitive labor markets where you as a
worker have lots of firms you can work
for and they're all clearly in front of
you and they all offer a wage and you
can see it
what we're saying is letting the firm's
have for information about the laborers
the firm's essentially uh I think I
described this so once again the firms
are from the firm's perspective they do
a perfect information though the wages
aren't it yes right the workers aren't
the same they've different marginal
products the were the firm's no you're
better than you or vice versa
but from the firm's perspective the main
from the workers perspective it's just I
think of the workers as the consumers in
a perfectly competitive output market
very competitive output market the
consumers can easily shop across all the
firms they might buy from and a
perfectly competitive input market
workers can easily shop among all firms
they might work for okay that's a good
good question other questions
okay now let's think about the long run
this was the short run let's think for a
minute about long run labor demand big
for a second about long run labor demand
well what's different the only thing
that's different isn't a long run
capital can adjust as well
Tilly's differed about the long run all
the intuition everything's the same
it's just that capital can adjust as
well and what this means is that
long-run labor demand is more elastic
than short-run labor demand okay so we
could see this in Figure 15 - okay so
the figure shows 2 different short-run
labor demand curves at two different
levels of capital okay so the short-run
labor demand when K when K bar equals 32
is that lower one the short-run labor
demand when K bar equals 108 is the
higher one and what this says is in the
short-run you've got these two labor
demand curves in the long run you could
optimize capital you can pick a point on
either curve depending on which level of
capital you choose and by definition
that allows you to that allows you to be
more elastic and choosing your labor
you're more flexible because you can
optimize not just over workers but over
machines as well it's the same intuition
we developed before talking about
short-run and long-run costs that the
long-run cost curve was a lower envelope
for the short-run cost curse same thing
here
this
why's that the long run labor demands
more elastic because I basically am more
flexible I can I not only could choose a
long a curve I can choose which curve I
use and by definition that means that
the long run more is more elastic okay
just a small sort of side point there
now last thing I want to talk about here
is capital demand we talked about
short-run long where labor demand sorry
about capital demand it basically is the
same thing capital demand is the exact
same intuition you want to get machines
until the marginal product of capital
mark the next machine times the price
you get for your good equals the
interest rate it's the same condition so
we want to hire workers so the march
product of labor times the price of our
good equals the wage rate want to invest
in more machines until the marginal
product of capital of the next machine
times the price for our good is equal to
the interest rate so it's exact same
logic here's the marginal cost the next
sheet of kappa remember we talked about
the intuition the always renting things
so think about renting a machine the
next machine costs are to rent do you
want to rent it well it depends what
will it produce and what can you sell
that stuff for so you rent the next
machine if the if the marginal part of
capital if the goods it produces times
what you sell those goods for you want
to do that until that equals the
interest rate okay
questions about that yeah starting next
lecture right now I think I just put
this down here we'll come back to it but
I'm gonna focus on labor for this
lecture okay so let's focus on labor
and let's so I just put that down then
we'll come back to capital but focus on
labor for a minute it makes you
understand where labor demand comes from
now let's talk about where does labor
supply come from we talked about fur at
the firm level labor supplies perfectly
elastic so go back to figure fifteen one
that was a firm level curve okay that
was a firm level curve that's a
perfectly elastic latest light to affirm
but that doesn't mean Labor's light to
the markets perfectly elastic so now we
want to derive market labor supply so
I'll call this deriving market labor
supply deriving market labor supply okay
now this is basically the question of
how do we model how hard people want to
work this is once again getting to what
economic society exciting ok you sort of
knew that economics was involved in how
much Ford cart charge for a car but you
probably did might not have thought so
much about economics was involved in
deciding how hard you work but it is and
we're gonna use the same tools of
consumer choice indeed I used to teach
us right now as an application of
consumer choice but now I teach it here
because it's the same tools of consumer
choice but now consumers instead of
choosing good a versus good B are gonna
choose how hard they're gonna work ok so
basically like any choice there's a
trade-off there's a trade-off on the one
hand if you work harder you get more
stuff so you bring home more income you
can buy more pizzas and cookies ok
remember we talked about income as a
fixed thing your parents gave you but in
reality sorry kids you're gonna have to
make your own money someday ok in
reality you're gonna make it oh why it's
not gonna be given to you and so if you
want to buy more pizza and cookies
you're gonna have to raise your why it's
not going to be given ok so the reason
you want to work harder is to buy more
pizzas and cookies the reason you don't
want to work harder it's because you're
not an MIT student ok that is normal
people actually don't like work
newsflash
okay normal people actually like leisure
there's the thing called leisure it
turns out okay normal people like it
okay so the trade-off for regular people
is always a hard thing to teach at MIT
okay
is that basically Pete the trade-off is
if you work harder you get more stuff
but you spend more time doing something
you don't want to do now this is weird
we're gonna talk about trade-offs before
touch out the trade-offs between Goods
pizza and cookies now we're talking
about the trade-off between a good and a
bad the good is more stuff to eat the
bad is working harder and we don't
really know how to model that so the
trick we're going to use here is we're
gonna flip the bad into a good instead
of modeling labor we're gonna model
leisure so to get labor supply we're
gonna model leisure supply and then just
flip it around and get labor supply okay
so that is we're gonna say your ultimate
labor supply the amount of hours you
work the amount you work amount of hours
you work call them H okay is equal to 24
minus is equal to 24 minus leisure call
it in good let's call it leisure cuz
legs let's call it little L lashes
little out the amount of hours you work
is 24 minus the hours of leisure you
take what that means is I don't have to
model the bad I can model the good and
the juice is simple you know reflection
equation to get the the bad okay so this
is the trick in economics a good
modeling trick
we don't mom a bad stone under the
trade-off between a bad and a good we
don't want them to do the trade a 15-2
goods so turn the bat into a good don't
model work model leisure don't model
your hours you work model how many hours
of leisure okay this is a general
modeling trick so what we want to ask is
now not how do you derive to supply of
labor how do you derive the demand for
leisure how how do we derive how much
leisure people want well once I say it
that way you know what to do which is I
just said they're two goods consumption
and leisure I wonder how much of one
good you choose of each good you choose
well that's a consumer consumer choice
problem you know how to do that okay
so basically take figure fifteen three
okay in Figure fifteen three now instead
of doing Pizza versus cookies now our
decision is all consumption so they like
consumption as a bundle okay
versus leisure so on the y-axis is how
the goods you choose on the x-axis is
how much leisure you take okay it says n
but actually cliff should be little L
okay should be little L so let's call
that little L okay so basically as you
go more positive on the x-axis that's
more leisure but because this equation
that implies as you go to the left on
the XS that's more work okay yeah
each is hours of work inches hours of
work so as you go to the left you work
more so you go to the right you take
more leisure but we're modeling the good
which is leisure and then we just go to
our standard we go to our standard
consumer choice equation we have a
budget constraint and preferences the
indifference curve comes from your
utility function it comes from your
indifference between how much you
consume and how much leisure you take
and the universe curve comes from like
any consumer choice decision but instead
of choosing to be pizza and cookies now
it's how much stuff you want for this
how much larger you want to take so it's
the same sort of indifference curve the
budget constraint comes from the what
the market tells you is the cost of
leisure what is the price of leisure
what is the price of leisure someone
else price is an opportunity costs are
the same thing in economics here's once
again where it gets interesting to apply
what we've learned which is that
basically this is why what's the end
Akali comics the dismal science instead
of having fun sitting around we're
telling you you know by the way you
could be working and making a wage so
you're actually spending
money by taking leisure by taking less
you are spending money what are you
spending you're spending the money you
could be earning so the opportunity so
lesser has a price and the price of
leisure is the wage it's what you could
be earning if you were working so the
budget constraint has the slope of minus
W so if you leave the budget constraint
you could take 24 hours of leisure and
have zero consumption okay that's the
x-axis intercept or you take no leisure
and have 24 W worth of consumption okay
so basically that is the trade-off you
face one other modeling trick couple of
muscle couple of modeling tricks here
modeling trick one is a model of good
not too bad okay
modeling trick 2 is I wrote on the
x-axis goods but we don't think in
quantities we think of dollars so to
make life easier I just said let's
assume the price of the average good is
$1 that way you can it that's called the
that's just a normalization ok which
allows you to think in terms of dollars
of goods rather than quantity of goods
that's another modeling trick we'll do
we call making a numeraire good ok you
don't remember that term but the point
is a trick we'll do is we want to model
dollars not quantities we just make the
quantities cost a dollar and then we can
model quantities basically as dollars as
I said the trick we're doing so the
y-axis is dollars but it's also
quantities because it may be the price
of everything be a dollar okay it's just
another trick that makes life easier
okay so - modeling tricks here
the numeraire trick which is making the
phrase a dollar so quantities become
dollars and the good and the bad is good
trick which is model the good and the
reverse that to get the bad having done
that we know what to do we get an
optimum which is the tangency between
the indifference curve in the budget
constraint and we're done and so what do
you do you choose we're gonna call it L
will car little L you choose little L
star hours of leisure which means you
choose 24 - little L star hours of work
okay
so basically you sat down you made the
decision how much do I want to eat first
is how much you want to watch TV you
make that trade-off and that determines
how hard
work okay now yeah well that's what and
in substance that should that would be
in your utility function or that would
it would be in your Tilly function
and/or your budget constraint that would
be true
absolutely but that would be a feature
that wouldn't change this maximization
problem just changed the underlying
structure of the equations that go into
the maximization problem okay so
basically now what's really interesting
about this is now we finally understand
why we learned all that [ __ ] about
income and substitution effects remember
let's take those Sosa's facts and you're
probably saying like why do I care price
goes up quantity goes down why do I care
here's why you care because now it gets
really interesting okay because when
we're doing a substitution effects for a
good they work together as long as the
good was normal they work together when
the price went up you substitute away
from the good and you were poor so he
could sum it down for two reasons now a
normal lesser effect is an inferior
labor effect what I mean by that is that
when your wage goes up you work more
through the substitution effect but now
you're richer and when you're richer you
buy more of everything including leisure
so if you take more leisure you do less
labor so the income effect naturally
goes against the substitution effect oh
this is a couple times don't worry big
game affect me actually goes against the
substitution effect here for consumption
goods the income effect naturally work
together okay and we're we almost never
saw sort of a given good type phenomenon
we think of effect could sort of switch
the overall effect for labor that's much
more likely it's much more likely not
because leisure not because of any
inferior good it's because leisure czar
normal good and Labor's the opposite of
leisure so once again let me say it
again the wage goes up
the substitution effect when the think
of leisure is a good when the wage goes
up that's the price of leisure going up
when the price of a good goes up the
substitution effect says you want less
of it okay so when the wage goes up the
substitution effect says that leisure
goes down right because you want to
substitute a weight lesser just got more
expensive you now feel worse singer I'm
watching TV because you could be out
there making more money yeah okay so the
substitution effect says that leisure
goes down okay
the income effect says that you are
richer right your wage went up you're
richer when you're richer you want more
of all normal goods leisure for non MIT
students is a normal good so you want
more of it so here with the in with
consumption goods when they were normal
being a musician effects work together
with labour and leisure they work
opposite so what this says the
substitution effect says take more
leisure which means work take less
luxuries work harder work more hours but
the effect says take more leisure which
means work less hours so you don't know
what the net effect is so that's why we
do income and substitution effects
because in a case like this they get
much more interesting yes now your
question no this is your income your
actual cash income you are now richer
and when you're richer you spend more on
everything so think of it this way what
to get imagine you're not MIT student a
normal guy okay if we won the lottery if
you guys won the lottery you would use
that to do a startup okay if a normal
person won the lottery
they used it to not work okay
that's the income effect okay when
normal win lotteries they don't go work
harder they don't work okay so that's
the
wait you are now richer because your
wage went up so you work less and that
offsets it so let's show this in a graph
let's go back to our income and
substitution effect graphs like I do
before figure 15 4 ok now we're back to
once again this is just applied consumer
theory ok let's go back to the income
and substitution effects we start with
budget constraint one at wage one and we
have our initial tangency at a ok with
with leisure of n1 or a little l1 now
our wage goes up our wage goes up
therefore the budget constraint pivots
up think of what that means you can
still only have 24 hours of leisure
that's a fixed point but as you would
take less leisure you make more money so
the budget right now pivots up well that
has two effects the first is the
substitution effect
remember how we get that we draw an
imaginary budget constraint at the new
price ratio the price ratio is just W
because I've assumed the price of goods
is 1 the new price ratio tangent to the
old indifference curve that is point B
so the substitution effect says take
less leisure
ok you're the price of leisure has gone
up so holding utility constant want to
take less leisure the income effect
however says you are now richer so take
more leisure so the income effect goes
the opposite way of the substitution
effect naturally not you don't need a
weird thing for that to happen like with
pizza and cookies it comes naturally so
for normal goods being effect goes the
opposite way now in this case we end up
with less you're still going down we end
up with the wage goes up leisure Goes
Down and therefore labor supply goes up
so we end up with our standard intuition
which is I tell you if I'm going to pay
you more you're gonna work harder or
less hard the standard tuition is I work
more hard ok but as figure 15 5 shows it
would not be super odd to get a Giffen
good effect here which is the wage goes
up the substitution effect shifts you to
the left but the income effect shifts
you even more to the right
and you actually end up with more
leisure so once again my intuition if I
say to you the price of pizza went up
what happens your demand for pizza you
think of a standard you say well I'm
gonna demand less pizza if I save you
the wage went up what happened to how
hard you work it's not clear think of a
simple example think of yourself
actually back before en mi cheese
student when you were a kid saving for
something you were saving to buy a bike
and the bike was 150 bucks ok bike was
200 bucks and you're earning 10 bucks an
hour ok so you had to work 20 hours to
get the bike now I gave you a race to 15
hours to $15 an hour or to $20 an hour
would you work harder or less hard well
if all you want is the bike you'd work
less hard you never to wear 20 hours of
oil to work 10 hours so in fact a higher
wage cause you to work less hard that's
not that bizarre a case right that makes
sense
the point is it's actually quite
sensible that you couldn't end up with
labor supply being a gift and good with
a higher wage causing you to work less
it's not a crazy outcome given Goods and
consumer goods are crazy it's not at all
crazy to think that in cases like having
a target a purchased target a higher
wage will cause people to work less yeah
absolutely applies there's no violation
here we haven't violated any of the laws
all we've done is just set income
effects so because it didn't apply with
giving goods - it's all just saying
income effects domini substitution
effects which we thought was sort of
gonna be pretty bizarre in the
consumption good context but it's not a
law bizarre in the labor supply context
this is pretty wild what this says is
that basically you've got a situation
where even the normal world you could
get the paying workers more makes them
work less which is kind of bizarre ok
questions about that about that
intuition or the math of the grass or
well the math even gun but the graphs do
the math on Friday the graphs or
anything ok
let's then say well does that happen in
reality
what does the evidence say let's go to
the evidence what does the evidence say
okay and there may be sort of no
question more worked on in economics
than the elasticity of labour supply or
the shape of the labor supply curve
there is thousands of articles written
on this question okay and what I want to
do here to make the intuition easy I
want to go back into that flourish or
circa 40 years ago when it was sort of
the initial burst of interest in this
and like the 1970s 98 was a burst of
interest in this and what the literature
did was it look separately at men and
married women because most women were
married and back then we didn't care
about single women okay okay was it was
it was a dark time okay so the look at
men and women and married women and
asked what was their Alessi's a labor
supply well let's think for a second
about what we'd expect and to do that
let's think about the substitution
effect and the income effect let's start
with men the male substitution effect
let's so substitute back men versus
married women who has a bigger
substitution effect in Y that is when
the wage goes up who who has a bigger
substitution response to that and why
men are married women think about the
world you know you've seen Matt together
at the Mad Men world or the world you
know circa 40 years ago you guys seen
enough TV and stuff to know how life was
a little bit okay
so who's gonna respond who's the bigger
guy well they certainly were in the
1970s men have a bigger substitution
effect okay um let's that's one option
yeah
right so it's actually married women
because men are already working 40 hours
they can't there's no so think about a
married man in 1975 okay men didn't
raise their kids men quite frankly get
much of a [ __ ] about their kids okay men
just worked that's what men did in 1975
okay they worked and they work their
forty hours and they went home okay
maybe they work less or more than forty
hours but certainly the notion is saying
well the wage went up maybe I'll take
more leisure never lacrosse demands mine
in 1975 because what were they gonna do
there's no one to play golf with they
didn't want time to spend time with
their kids what were they gonna do
whereas women had a real substitution
possibility okay
this was an era women were entering the
labor force the real opportunities for
work but it was also fine to hang out at
home you know a lot of your friends are
in at home you can take care of your
kids or a lot of things to do so women
had a much larger substitution effect
than men okay because men what remember
what's the substitution effect it's
about the next best alternative for men
there was no next best alternative Oh
should work you know basically G 9:00 to
5:00 on a weekday there was nothing else
to do okay for women there was other
things to do which is you can hang out
with friends who weren't working or you
could take care of the kids yeah okay
well let's but once again if I'm a man
you might think that I could then but
then once again if I work oh the
substitution effect could work that way
for overtime but let's talk about just
the decision to work at all at some
sense or the decision to work so to your
first 40 hours overtimes hard because
then you get paid more etc okay
now let's go to the other side let's go
to the income effect so let's not say
this is zero let's say it's small okay
so this is big and this is small because
you can work a little bit of overtime or
something like that and some men didn't
care about the kids I'm obviously being
facetious so it could be some some men
were willing to spend time with their
kids etc okay now let's go to the income
effect for whom is the income effect
couldn't be bigger men or women whom is
the income effect going to be bigger
yeah
because because there they have a goal
like they need X amount of money to
provide for their family so like if they
reach exactly there's actually two
reasons it's men one you're more likely
the target income two is you can't have
an income effect if you don't work okay
the income effect is proportional to how
hard you were working if you weren't
working then there's no income effect
right income effect is essentially the
income effect for labor is essentially
the hours x d h dy what Manny said was a
reason why DHD Y might be bigger for men
than women because they have these
targets more relevantly if women weren't
working they didn't have the h this is
zero so the income affects zero so for
men this was big and for women this was
small okay put this together and what
does it suggest about the relative
shapes of Labour's fly for men and women
so I'm raise their hand and tell me what
does it suggest about the labor supply
curve would look like for men and women
in the Sierra okay given given we given
the intuition we talked about here what
is suggest the female a male the married
women layers fighting that male air
supply curve should look like you guys
can get this come on okay well let's
talk what do we talk about we talked
about the substitution effect if the
wage goes up it leads to more leisure
which means at least a more labor supply
by the income effect if the wage goes up
at least two less labor supply so for
men with us for women with a big
substitution effect and a small income
effect this suggests a standard steep
upwards and standard upward sloping
supply curve think of the income effect
being zero then we get the standard
substitution effect we know the sign of
that so for women this suggests an
upward sloping supply curve just like a
substitution effects just a downward
sloping demand curve for men it's not
clear you could very much get a Giffen
effect here
because basically there's not much
opportunity for substitution but they
might work a lot less if they get rich
okay so that is sort of this the that's
what I like this example it's hard well
like this example sort of illustrates
how substitution effects can come
together to get a lower bottom and
bottom line answer what do we know what
we know is that actually evidence is
that female layers fly was very elastic
that circa this era female has an
elasticity of between 0.5 and 1 that if
you raised women's wage by 10% there was
a five to ten percent increase in their
labor supply which is pretty not elastic
elastic but reasonably elastic okay
whereas for men it was pretty much zero
it wasn't negative it wasn't positive as
basically zero basically men just worked
40 hours and then went home okay so
basically an era where for women the
layers light was very elastic and of the
standard direction higher wage leads you
to work harder an upward sloping supply
curve but for men it was pretty much a
vertical supply curve maybe even a bit
backward bending maybe even a wrong
signed supply curve but pretty much you
could think of it as zero okay now what
do we think has happened in the 40 years
since - these two numbers so unless this
is rhomin are between 0.5 and 1 and men
of 0 what do we think is what happened
to these two numbers in the 40 years
since these these studies and why what
do you think has happened to these
elasticity estimates and why yeah women
what do you think's happened to the
female estimate because
right well first of all this is gonna
come down because in fact it's now more
standard just to work right in fact now
for a woman today in many communities
it's like being in mankind 70s which is
if you don't go to work there's no one
to hang out with okay so basically this
is going to get smaller and they're more
of a primary earner in the families this
is gonna get bigger
so in fact female labor supply has
fallen more to like about an elasticity
of about 0.2 it's actually fallen over
time now for men the question is do you
get the opposite effect actual immense
sort of care more about their kids now
and there's more sort of activities
going on during the day but in fact it
has it the fact mailers fly still was
pretty inelastic what's happened is kids
are now in childcare so basically we've
gone from a world where as wages went up
women went as men worked women either
worked or didn't work depending on the
wage and if they work the kids went in
childcare now men work and women work
and kids are in childcare and that's
basically the change the evolution of
the labor roughly speaking obviously
still female labor force participation
is only about 70 percent ok many women
still do stay home and raise their kids
and are in and out of the labor force
okay but by and large we move to a world
with just overall less elastic labor
supply yeah okay we're gonna get into
this and we talk about income
distribution what this is done is
allowed the average family household
test red water so it's the average two
family household today has the same
income as they did in the 1970s why
because workers aren't a ton less in
real terms than they did and that's
facts about inequality will come to that
face the average family in America
despite having going from the wife not
working to the wife working is no better
off than they were 40 years ago and that
has lots implications we'll talk about
okay so any other questions about that
so let me end with one final example
okay an application okay which is - the
problem - the problem we have in the
world of child labor it's a huge problem
around the world as kids being forced to
work was a huge problem in the u.s. till
the 20s
centuries huge problem around the world
because a work can often be dangerous
and bad for their health but B they
can't be going to school and have an
opportunity to better themselves if a
kid is spending all day working then
that kid is destined to a life of
working in the same crappy job because
there's no way to get the skills that
allows them to grow and go further okay
now one when wheat we will talk in the
next few lectures and a few lectures
about international trade and one
criticism of international trade is
people say well if you allow these
developing countries to sell more stuff
to developed world that will they'll put
the kids to work more so if we have free
trade and Vietnam can suddenly sell a
bunch of stuff to America that's more
kids are gonna put to work making that
stuff so one common argument you hear
against free trade is it's bad for kids
but in fact that argument is not
necessarily right because it ignores an
important point Manny the point that
that's right but the point it ignores is
free trade makes families richer and a
families are richer they may want to buy
more education for their kids so on the
one hand it's true free trade makes kids
more valuable in the labor force the
other hand it makes family richer and
then one more education for their kids
so to look at that to Dartmouth
professors did a study we looked at
Vietnam and looked at what happened when
Vietnam liberalized trade in rice so
let's go to figure fifteen six now we
haven't got international trade yet so
I'm just gonna sort of hand wave through
this you don't really understand this
graph except with the bottom line is
okay what happened was
but before trade liberalisation in
Vietnam before 1989 you could only sell
rice made in Vietnam in Vietnam so what
that meant was the supply of rice was S
sub V the demand for rice with D sub V
and you a matter of race always Q sub V
and kids worked in the rice paddies when
they liberalized trade suddenly Vietnam
could sell to a much larger market they
could sell to the world market D sub W
that's a bigger market so they were able
to
up there supply curve and sell more rice
okay they could sell more rice because
now there's such the whole world not
just to Vietnam okay you don't need
roads to the grass so much Dean tuition
if you give someone a bigger market
they're gonna make more stuff okay yeah
they let it set up and so I didn't think
they let more in okay well we'll come
back to international trade okay so
basically the point is there was there
was this demand shock that allowed them
to somewhere right so what effect does
that have on the market for child labor
let's go to highly complicated last
figure let me walk you through this here
is the market for child labor okay on
the x-axis is the amount of child labor
on the y-axis the wage of kids okay
we start at point one initial demand
initial supply wage one l1 now we
liberalize trade and that leads to more
demand for child labor because we want
to produce more rice so that shifts us
out to D two and point two so we have
more child labor that's bad but what
this ignores is families are now richer
and with the income effect they will buy
their kids education they'll pull their
kids out of working and put them in
school that's represented as a shift to
the left of the supply curve so we move
from point 2 to point 3 through the
income effect families in are richer and
indeed if the income effect is large
enough you could move to point four you
can actually have a reduction in child
labor why because the benefits of more
kids working in terms of producing more
rice is exceeded by the value to the
firm's of taking their of the families
of taking the extra money they're making
and putting it to education for their
kids and in fact the study showed that
we did move to a point like point four
okay we actually found that child labor
fell
when they liberalize trade that the that
the art the intuitive argument that gee
if they sell more more kids or go to
work is wrong that in fact when you sell
more guess more kids demand for more
kids but family is so rich they put
their kids in education rather than
their fields ok and that is a wonderful
sort of counterintuitive story of how
what economy I'll talk about economist
like free trade how free trade
connection of unexpected positive effect
we might think it's negative and there's
the question come up if you want to talk
but we got to end now so thank you for
staying minute extra and I will see you
guys on Wednesday